all right you know i got to ask you
about i mean what is the difference
between
this off season compared to last year's
off season
um
i feel like coming into this year we
will have a lot more familiarity with
everything going on
last year we were coming in learning a
new system
new coaches a lot of new faces and with
no off-season that was you know it kind
of
put us in a similar situation to other
teams in the league where you know you
didn't really have that off season to
prepare but now um your second year in
the system things should you know the
verb starts to sound really familiar um
the plays obviously look a lot familiar
so you just really start to get focused
on the the details of the of the offense
the little things that can really make
all the difference come season time
yeah even with that being said with last
year you guys still made the playoffs
what was the biggest takeaway
from you guys getting into the playoffs
last year
i think it showed a lot of resiliency
about our groups first especially like a
young team
a lot of unproven guys but we had a lot
of veterans on the team too
obviously the
the um you know the up and downs we had
with you know quarterbacks some went
down some you know got replaced so um
obviously that was adjustment but i feel
like this year coming up is gonna be um
you know a good measuring stick for us
to see can we build on what we did last
year i don't think anybody really came
into last year on the outside looking in
seeing us as a playoff team and you know
that division was up for grabs pretty
much the whole season and we just want
to put ourselves in a situation to be
able to compete for it at the end i feel
like we did that um in spite of all the
adversity we had went through so um you
know we're there's no secret that we're
obviously a team that's improving um
we've made a lot of great additions in
this offseason and it's about building
on that and and trying to be more
consistent throughout the year instead
of those up and down stretches that we
had
yeah you talk about being consistent is
that what you guys need to do in order
to really take that next step and maybe
some more consistent quarterback play as
well
um i think so but i think it starts with
everybody just focusing on their job i
know the quarterbacks are going to um
you know get right under coach turner
obviously we got fits in the building
who brings us that veteran presence and
that leadership so i think that'll
definitely help stabilize that position
a lot better too and um
i mean i just i mean like you gotta you
gotta come in i feel like the games that
we you know we were in most of the games
last year it was just one play here or
there you know i mean that make all the
difference in this league and i feel
like if we want to take that next step
we gotta um not start that slow in some
games and then finish strong as well we
would get up and then um you know the
consistency throughout the game wasn't
as necessary to what our standard we're
trying to build here so i think it's
just minimizing on the negative plays
that we had and finishing the game when
when we're in the lead
man talk about curtis samuel and what he
brings i think this kid is highly
underrated i think he's going to take a
lot of pressure off you and he's the guy
that you're going to have to definitely
deal with down the field
yeah well i've gotten obviously real
familiar with curtis's game over the
years and
he's really developed into a really good
receiver in this league he's so dynamic
what he can what he can do with the ball
and um you know i haven't been around
him until otas for a few years just to
see that the way he's developed his
route running tree and how he can run
any route from inside and out i mean i
think that that helps us versatility
wise
in our offense allows guys to play
different spots i could play the slot he
could play the slide i could play
outside he could play outside and um you
know he's going to add a lot of speed
and dynamic and play making ability to
our group and he can also catch the ball
out the back field and take chest sweeps
like
i mean i think he's a game breaker
honestly the way he the way he can uh
cut on a dime the way he can
get those extra yards after catch that's
something that
we've been missing in this offense and i
feel like adding that piece uh what he
brings his skill set to the table is
really going to help us this year
in your short time of
in your short time around ryan
fitzpatrick what has he shown you i mean
he's a veteran everywhere he goes he
wins people love him he's exciting like
what has he shown you
i think the two things that he's shown
me is one just the communication i think
that's really big with the quarterback
and the receiver especially
when you're first learning each other so
i think we've been able to try to take
advantage of this ota time to kind of
knock out some of the little things to
get on the same page of this offense so
when we come training camp we're kind of
honing in on the little things and come
game time week one then you know it's
ready for is ready for the season and so
i'd say just his communication his
feedback um i remember he's texting me
and he's watching clips that i've run uh
from last year talking about what i see
here
um you know if i get this leverage what
am i thinking just trying to get on the
same page which really helps him out but
it also helps me out because it it gives
me a little snapshot of what's going on
in his mind and jim and then just he
likes to have fun um he comes out here
and brings energy to our offense and the
guys and it's like it always seems like
he's been here for longer than he has
and i just think you know he's like a
chameleon he just seems to be able to
blend in and relate to guys and uh you
know he's smart so he's seen it all so i
think he has the instant credibility to
where guys um
you know want to follow him and want to
follow his direction but it's not like
he's coming in like this is his team you
know he's trying to earn his way and
earn the respect of everybody around
here too
coach rivera i have a lot of respect for
him i text him during the year text him
in the offseason we text back and forth
and i just have a lot of respect for
just his toughness mental toughness but
he also has done a great job of bringing
accountability and and making sure that
guys are held accountable uh what have
you what has he shown you um as a coach
he's a great man
yeah that's i mean that's the biggest
thing you said was that consistency that
one voice um you know you know the
expectation when you walk in the
building every day with coach rivera and
this coaching staff is to give
everything you got
make sure you know what you're doing on
and off the field handling your business
and and um carrying yourself like a pro
and i feel like um you know his message
permeates throughout the team and the
coaching staff so there's no confusion
of what the expectation is there's no
confusion on um how we're supposed to
practice how we're supposed to take care
of ourselves how we're supposed to
prepare and that that clarity um you
know it gives direction in it it sets a
standard to where um if you're not
living up to those expectations it makes
it pretty clear that you know you're not
necessarily in line with what we're
trying to do here and um you'll probably
end up having a conversation with them
so i just think that clarity and that
consistency in this message is big for
you know
guys at this level because um everybody
could play
you know at a very high level otherwise
they wouldn't be here but it's just the
little details that coach rivera has us
focusing on that's going to either make
it or make make or break our season and
i think that's why we took such a big
step from our rookie year than we were
here in the first year they got here
last year um just the way he
expects that excellence day in and day
out um
i think that really helps us and then
just seeing what he went through
obviously through his battle with cancer
it kind of just
put things in perspective at least for
me
because there's
so many other things that people are
going through that's bigger than
football but at the same time he never
let that hinder what he had to do and
his responsibilities as the head coach
he was always in here trying to give us
the energy and all that he had even
though he was you know battling cancer
so
when you have a guy like that especially
your leader your head coach who comes
with that workman's like mentality and
no excuses i mean you have no choice but
to fall in line and it makes you want to
fight even harder because you know you
got a guy that
obviously understands where you're
coming from as of being a former player
but also the expectations of what it's
like to
to to put a you know practices and games
together to where you're you're
competing for it all at the end of the
season
you guys are very talented on the
offensive side of the ball but you
trying to win championships and playoff
games we know it comes down to that
defense how good is it to be able to go
against that defense and see all them
young studs you got up there on that
defensive line and in the secondary it's
fun it's really fun uh practice very
very competitive um they're always
flying around they make a pick you know
they're acting like it's it's a party
out there but um i think it's a it's a
great advantage for us as a as an
offense to be able to go against them
guys every single day from the d-line to
the linebackers to the back end i mean
um they're very they're very first of
all they're talented second of all i
think they're really well coached um
they're very disciplined and everything
you earn in practice you know you know
that is earned then you're not really
giving up any free yards and practice
and i think that's going to help us come
to the games when we're seeing other
defenses and um you know i i put our
defense up there with anybody in the
league as far as a team that has the
potential to you know to be um
a very strong stout defense and i think
we're going to lean on that i think is
going to really play into our style of
offense and you know hopefully i could
get some turnovers for us and give us
great field position like they did last
year and then we got to help them out do
a better job and help them out this year
when they give a short field and create
those turnovers we got to capitalize
who are some of the guys around the
league that you compare yourself to
because you know as receivers you're
always looking at the stats the numbers
the catches but who are those two or
three guys that you say hey i'm checking
on these guys every single week
right um
i wouldn't necessarily say i compare
myself to anybody um i feel like i i do
a lot of things
uh pretty well but um i mean i respect a
lot of receivers in this league i'm a
fan of football first so um you know i
like to watch other guys i like to watch
you know devante adam stefan diggs
mike thomas when he's healthy obviously
julio
um you know i watch some mike evans too
just you know how physical he plays at
the line
um you know i know i'm missing some guys
obviously um but yeah
i'm just i'm just a student of the game
you know if i got an opponent coming up
you know that's where there's darius
slayer todavia swift some of these top
corners i like to try to watch these
other top receivers and see what those
battles are like because you know
you're gonna probably run similar a lot
of similar routes than they do even
though you may be in a different offense
so i like to kind of see how those guys
go against those top top talent and and
kind of see where i measure up but um
it's it's fun being a part of such a
young group of receivers where you feel
like um you know there's tall guys
there's smaller guys they're shifty guys
these guys are playing the slide outside
i think um you know wide receiver
position is in good hands in the nfl
right now and you know i know we're all
jock in to to be in that in that
conversation of the best guy
what areas when you look at your game we
always go into the off season and we say
a b and c we need to improve on in our
game what what are some of the things
that you have to do to prove your game
um i i feel like i want to do a better
job at the line um you know being the
fast guy that i am i don't want to
necessarily rush my releases at the line
like i kind of have been um i want to be
a little bit kind of dictate a little
bit more not trying to react to what the
db is doing more so dictate and have him
react off me um i feel like i can use
that to strengthen my game with my
ability to get off press coverage and
and and um
and get free releases but at the same
time it has to
you know
dbs are smart they'll start recognizing
splits and they'll start recognizing
formations and then you kind of kind of
still got to win on a slam against
inside leverage man i mean that's tough
but um you got to learn how to do that
and i feel like just that's the biggest
thing for me going into this next year
is that consistency
not necessarily having that drop off at
the end of the year i know i was a
little banged up but at the end of the
day
um if you're going to be the number one
receiver for a team you got to be able
to
continue to get stronger throughout the
end of the season so i just want to
really focus on that as well and and
continue to just get better my consist
my contested catches as well
a lot of passes aren't going to be you
know nobody around you that's very rare
in the nfl so i want to continue to win
those 50 50 balls because that not only
gives um you know the quarterback
confidence but it gives everybody else
confidence when you see a receiver
coming with a 50 50 ball i feel like
that gives you momentum and energy
throughout the whole team and if we
could create more of those situations
and myself included setting that tone
then i feel like we're going to have a
really strong year as a wide receiver
group
look what are some of your specific
goals like are you a guy that comes into
the season that says hey i want to be
all pro i want to be a pro bowler i want
to catch a hundred passes do you have
those type of goals or do you just say
hey i'm just going to work and whatever
my team needs me to do i'm just gonna do
i think it's more so of that um i try
not to get too wrapped up in the
statistical part of the game obviously
we're judged off of a production so i
obviously want to be as productive as
possible but um you know i don't really
come into the season like i need this
many catches of this many yards this
many touchdowns i just need to be able
to do whatever my team calls me to do um
you know some games it'll be more so in
the run game some games it'll be i have
to take the load and catch eight to ten
passes i mean i feel like i'm the type
of player where i'm i have the
versatility to be able to do whatever
i'm asked to do it's just a matter of
being consistent weekend and week out
and getting stronger as the season
progresses and when you when they need
me most that's when i come down with
those plays so that's the type of
pressure i put on myself that's the type
of expectation i have for myself so um i
feel like my teammates feel that and um
i'm just continually trying to work so i
can continue to gain their trust and
continue to have that you know that um
that that relationship with fitz or
wherever the quarterback is um where
they could trust that 17 is going to be
open
yeah speaking of which you've you know
as a receiver dealing with so many
different quarterbacks kind of coming in
and out and the thing i like about you
you never caught an attitude you never
you know powdered anything like that you
just went out and played how difficult
is it as a receiver to have so many
different quarterbacks thrown to you and
how big of an adjustment have you had to
make because of so many different guys
torn to you yeah it's it's it's just
challenging i'm not going to say it's
easy but at the same time
you know i've learned to not make any
excuses and my job is to produce at the
end of the day and i feel like one of my
main jobs playing receiver is to make
sure the quarterback is as comfortable
as possible so whatever they need
whether it's the extra reps during
practice after practice whether we need
to have some side conversations like um
my job is to make sure that you know
they can trust me when it comes sunday
and they have a guy that they could go
out there and and know he's going to be
where he needs to be where he needs to
be there and going to make the play and
so it's challenging because a lot of
quarterbacks take different drops um
their timing the type of ball they like
to throw
the way they throw the ball against
certain leverage it's kind of hard
without getting those you know those
those practice reps but i feel like we
do a pretty good job especially last
year we did a good job of um trying to
get on the same page whether it was alex
or taylor or dwayne or
kyle i mean i played with four different
guys and um you know they all brought
to the table you know i mean by the end
of the day the number one thing that
couldn't change was um i was out there
going to be able to make that play when
they needed it because if your you know
your top guys aren't out there making
those plays then that affects everyone
you know i mean especially your
quarterback so i didn't really get into
the mindset of just complaining like
dang it's another guy coming in it's
just like all right it's another guy
coming in let me try to make him look as
good as possible and let's try to get on
the same page so um
i think you know hopefully this year we
have you know not as many injuries and
and more consistency there and i think
we will especially with um guys more
comfortable with each other coming into
this year
all right i gotta ask you because i'm
just curious because i respect you as a
receiver who's the best wide receiver in
nfl and who's the best cornerback in the
national football league
do you have anybody else that you just
have a lot of respect for that no one
really talks about as a corner or even a
wide receiver
yeah um i'll go corner first i like jair
like it's alexander's game a lot um i
don't think he necessarily gets the
covers that he
that he should i mean
i think he's really savvy the way he
plays um he plays really well in zone he
plays well in manny super competitive um
yes and i really like his game i mean
we've got a corner like that who's going
to compete you know he may give up some
but you know he's going to come back and
probably get you one or two so
um
you know i like compete against guys
like that and he's one of many but
that's one of the guys off the top of my
head where i feel like you know he's one
of the top guys but they may not
necessarily get that recognition and um
on the receiver end i feel like
obviously guys know about you know diggs
and
and devante adams and tyrone kill i mean
there's just so many guys
one guy i probably like i mean i like
watching amari cooper a lot honestly the
way he runs his routes is real real
smooth especially in short areas i feel
like when he gets that press coverage
he's really good at being able to
separate in tight areas and and then
take those slants for a touchdown so you
know especially with him being a
division i get to kind of watch him a
lot to go against other corners in our
division to see um you know how they how
they play off him but another guy i feel
like
um i like a lot is i like mike evans
game you know people don't really
necessarily necessarily notice how well
he he could get behind guys like he
could really stretch the field for being
as big as he is
he's strong at the point of catch like
um so i really respect the way he plays
the game and he's a dude who don't
really get a lot of coverage but he
don't really talk a lot either you know
what i mean like some guys cry because
they don't really get that recognition
or that that um that attention that
other guys get but he just puts his head
down and he works so i respect him for
that and um but like i said i got a lot
of respect for a lot of the receivers in
this league and it's cool to be a part
of such a fun group of guys um you know
trying to take this position to the next
level
last question with with all these young
wide receivers getting drafted what
advice would you give them because
you're you're a young man that has a
great head on his shoulders i mean
you've been productive you never
complain you try to do all the right
things but what advice would you give a
lot of these young wide receivers coming
to the
league um first of all i think i'd
probably say um first thing you're
coming in whether you're a first round
pick or you're an undrafted guy come in
and know what you're doing i feel like i
shared was one that you care and two is
only going to help you out because you
know when i came in as a third round guy
and kind of expected to play special
teams or whatever i wanted to make sure
i may have got three or four reps of
practice you know i mean but i was going
to make sure those reps was
100
i knew what i was doing i was right
where i needed to be and i was going to
make the play i feel like that that goes
a long way from just not just your
coaches but it builds your confidence
because you're allowed you're able to
learn on the fly and adapt and adjust
practice to practice and i feel like
that's the biggest thing that coaches
want to see um is how you're being able
to retain the information and apply it
to the field and um it's hard for you to
be able to do that if you don't know
what you're doing because you're going
to be playing slow you're going to be
kind of confused and you're not going to
be able to necessarily play as fast as
you want to and the second second thing
i say is just have confidence um you
know
it's still football at the end of the
day obviously these guys are better than
you've seen in college but at the end of
the day i think it helps that you know
what you're doing and having that
confidence that you're going to make
that play because once you make it one
time then you make it again and then you
start building that that trust with the
quarterback and then your your coach is
like oh shoot we got to get him the ball
you know what i mean so it comes to a i
think it comes down to the
accountability and the trust factor that
really helps you be able to take that
next step as a receiver coming in to
where um you know you're you're a guy
that now on third down the game's on the
line they're calling your number i feel
like at the end of the day that as a
receiver that's what you want to be and
um that should be your mindset when they
when the game's online they need a big
play they're calling your name so that
starts with knowing what you're doing
and then just the in and out repetition
of doing your job because then you build
that trust with everybody around you
[Applause]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports